[Music]
what's your relationship
with friday 10 years later it's really
sweet that that song in the end
could bring people even just the most
simple sense of joy that maybe it was
originally intended to
party and partying i have so much love
for
for that song and what that experience
brought me in the end because
even though it wasn't always easy it
definitely was not easy
um it you know i wouldn't be the person
that i am without what i learned
rebecca learned as a preteen that the
internet could get nasty
detailing her experience with bullying
in a 2017 essay for nbc news
after some music critics dubbed friday
the worst song
ever
but this year she flipped the script
releasing a funky remix that's gotten a
warmer reception from critics
while her all-new project rebecca black
was here is well
here now
[Music]
so between your last couple of singles
and then getting into um
worth it for the feeling it really
sounds like you've gone through
some stuff i obviously came out as queer
last year and a lot of this project is
very heavily queer and
it's about a relationship that meant
so much to me and and the person that i
am now coming out as as queer last year
what was that like for you people have
just been
so incredibly welcoming and supportive
to me
and so many people in my audience and i
have so many incredible fans who are
queer themselves and have
shared their stories and i i almost feel
like i owe it to them
to share mine in a way and now rebecca
will see
all those fans when she goes on tour at
the start of next year
what is it going to be like to have to
pare down and pack a couple of bags and
go on tour
i will do whatever i need to do to get
on that road because i am just so
thrilled to get out of my own house